Go ahead, Miriam. Can you hear us? Hi.
How are you all? Hi. We're pretty good.
Pretty good. Uh, sorry. I don't want to
take up your time. It's not on topic. Is
this okay? No, it's it's it's perfectly
fine. It's we we do this not for debate
sake, but it it seems like you're
someone who is seeking and has genuine
questions, so you you get priority.
Uh, okay.
Uh, I stumbled upon David's video of the
Islamic Dilemma. I've never heard of it
before. Uh, and I watched it and I got
very angry and I blocked him. Oh no.
Darn it. That's what I That's what I
would do. That's a good idea. And then
put it stuck in my head. So it was just
annoying me. And then uh last night I
had this weird dream uh where I was in
my family and uh some Islamists tried to
unalive us uh if we don't believe in uh
Islam and then Jesus showed up and uh
saved me.
Whoa. My uh and these Islamists for some
reason ended up analying my family
members. Anyway, which was very weird.
Uh, and then in the dream, I remember
asking him uh for some sign or some like
uh I I never pictured Jesus, but this is
what I just knew it was him and uh I I
asked for some sign and then you're
alive came up today.
Oh, hey. Hey, hey, Miriam. I just want
to point out while you were while you
were talking, this made me this gave me
a flashback to my friend Nibil who left
Islam and became a Christian a long time
ago. He uh we were having discussions
about so we became best friends in
college. So, and we people people
thought it was awesome that the you
know, you got a Christian and a Muslim
who are best friends and always hanging
out together and so on. Uh but we'd be
arguing about Christianity and Islam a
lot. And we went we went through all the
topics that we that were most important.
We um examined the evidence for Jesus
death by crucifixion, his resurrection
from the dead, the reliability of the
New Testament, his claims to be divine.
We went through all that stuff. Then we
were investigating the Quran and its
preservation and the character of
Muhammad and Muhammad's supposed
miracles about various things and so on.
So we spent years studying all these
things and the result was Nabil
eventually got to a point where he was
saying Islam really makes sense to me
and I believe in Islam but there's this
other thing out there Christianity and
they do have good evidence for what they
believe. So I'm not sure I'm not sure
what to believe right now. I don't know.
And he actually he actually told God he
said
um there's a case for Christianity and
there's a case for Islam. I don't even
I'm not even sure I'm unbiased enough to
make this decision. So, could you could
you please just give me a sign? He said
this while he was in a hotel room and he
prayed. Could you please just give me a
sign so that I know? And he said the
room that he was in uh it faded to black
and all he saw were crosses everywhere,
different colored crosses everywhere. Um
but he didn't want to make it a
massively important decision just based
on seeing a bunch of crosses which could
have been just in in his imagination.
So, at that point, he asked God for a
dream. Could you show me in a dream what
I'm supposed to believe? And what what
you were talking about sounded like
Nibil's interpretation of the dream.
Although his was way his was way
weirder. Uh, in his dream, he's uh he's
on what he thinks is a mountain. He's on
this mountain with other people in this
dream, but suddenly he can zoom out and
look at where he actually is. like he
sees it from some other mountain looking
down and he sees that he's not actually
on a mountain. He's on this giant
iguana. And the iguana eventually turns
and sees him looking down at the
mountain at the mountain, what he thinks
is a mountain, but it was actually this
iguana. The iguana turns to him, sees
him and is about to kill him. Um when a
cricket shows up and chops the thing's
head off. chops the iguana's head off.
And he actually looked up what these
symbols mean in a in a dream book. And
this iguana is supposed to be some enemy
that's there to destroy you. And the
cricket represents a friend who shows up
to uh to a friend that shows up with
good intentions and so on. Anyway, he
interpreted he interpreted the mountain
that he was on as Islam. He thinks he's
on this solid mountain. but zooming out
and actually getting a better
perspective of it, it's actually
something that's there to destroy him
and it's and it's and it's about to eat
him. And then he inter he interpreted
according to this dream book that he's
looking up, the cricket is Christ that
shows up and rescues him from uh from
Islam which is about to destroy him and
so on. So anyway, he that's how he
interpreted it. But he said this is too
symbolic. This is too symbolic to for me
to base an important decision about my
future on. So he asked God, he says,
"Can you give me another dream, one that
I don't need to interpret this? You
know, an iguana and a cricket. I don't
know how to interpret this stuff. Can
you give me something that I don't need
to interpret?" Then he had a dream where
he's outside a room and he's looking
into the room. He said, "There's a
there's a narrow door. He's outside the
door and he's looking in and there's a
feast inside." and he sees me at the
feast and he calls out and he says,
"David, I thought we were supposed to
eat together and he says I don't look
over at him and I just say, "You never
responded." Wow. Anyway, he has that
dream and then he calls me and he says,
"David, uh, I had a dream. Um, do do
Christians believe that God can say
things in dreams?" And I I said, "Well,
you you do have in the Bible people, you
know, being given dreams like Joseph and
so on." So, yeah, we believe you can
have you can have dreams. and he
explains the dream and he said, "So, how
would you interpret that?" And I
answered him and I said, "I don't have
to interpret that. You just dreamed
yourself right into a parable of the
Bible." And I said, "Grab your Bible,
open up to Luke." And he said that when
he opened up the Bible, the heading was
the narrow door. And he said that's what
he had noticed about the door is it was
just narrow for someone to fit through
and so on. But it's called the narrow
door. And that's talking about uh the
people of God being gathered at the
feast of Abraham, Isaac, and Jacob and
so on and someone being locked on the
outside where there will be weeping and
nashing of teeth. And so what he took
away there, what he took away from that
was he specifically prayed and you give
me a dream that I don't need to
interpret. And then when he told me the
dream, I said, you don't need to we
don't need to interpret that. It's
straight out of the Bible. It's it's you
just it's it's a parable straight out of
the Bible. So we went through that. And
even after that, he's still he was still
not sure. So he asked God for another
dream. And in his third dream, he's in
the mosque and there's a stairway in the
mosque and he's sitting on the stairs.
And then the leader of his sect of Islam
walks in and sits down on the floor and
he said, "I cannot be in a higher
position than the than the leader of my
sect of Islam, so I have to get down on
the floor as well." And then he tried to
get off the stairs cuz he's higher up.
and he tried to get off the stairs and
he said he couldn't. It was blocked. He
couldn't go down to get off the stairs.
He could only go up to get to get off
the stairs and he turned and looked and
the stairs were leading him up out of
the mosque. And so he took everything as
he's supposed to be leaving Islam. Uh
but anyway, yeah, that that first story
about someone being about to destroy you
and then Christ showing up and rescuing
you, uh that sounded exactly like what
Nibil dreamed. And I've heard things
like that a lot in the past from Muslims
who are seeking. I'm just confused why
me? Why not my family members for
example? What? Like what makes me
different? Because I heard from
Christian friends that Jesus loves
everyone and uh he wants to save
everyone. So why me not my family?
Can I can I speak to you Mariam? Um
don't be nervous. Um my name is Doc. I
used to be a Muslim. Um the answer is
Jesus comes to every person in a
different way depending on their
personality, what they are. He comes to
every person. The way I see it is um
well what happened to me was I never saw
Jesus in a dream or a vision or
anything. What I did was I spoke to him
directly. He's not in the room. But I
pretended he's in the room. And I said
to him, Jesus, I was confused. I heard
Christians speak and I heard Muslims
speak. I said, it's either one or the
other is true. Can't be can't be both
true. So I said to Jesus, Jesus, if you
are like what Christians are saying,
show me. And I came to the Lord Jesus
because he did show me. Um he he he
never came to me in I didn't see him,
but I sensed his presence. And um I was
changed overnight. It it was like a
miracle and I hadn't even read the Bible
or anything. Um so I came to Jesus but
the way that Jesus came to into my home,
my family's home is through me. After I
read and I understood what it is and I
believed, I told them. So that's how I
see that that how they will get it. So
it's not that Jesus chooses you and not
your family. That's not how it works. He
comes to every person in a different way
as the vessel too. Yeah. As as a vessel.
So sometimes it will come to you through
a dream. I wasn't um I I I I prayed for
a dream and all that, but that wasn't
the way into me. You know, I didn't need
that. So Jesus didn't come to me that
way. But you had the dream, which is
incredible. Blessing. It's a blessing to
see Jesus himself like wow. But um it's
probably what you needed. But can I ask
you, have you prayed? Like have you
asked Jesus? And that was my next
question. Uh because I also uh heard uh
uh Christians
uh say that if you call for him, he will
answer you. How do you What do you mean
call for him? Like hello Jesus.
Just like you're speaking Just like
you're speaking to me now. Um that's
Yeah. What? Well, I tell you what I did.
I was in a room by myself. In fact, the
whole house was empty. I I chose it that
way. And then the man that uh said to
speak to Jesus said to get on your
knees. So I got on my knees. And when I
did, something in my heart opened and it
humbled me to the possibility that it
could be true. Like you need to put
everything away. All your family, your
pride, your upbringing, your language,
your religion, Islam, all that. Cuz
Islam fills you with like an identity,
like a pride. Like this is it, this is
the truth, all that. You don't you need
to put all that to the side and just
really like really ask as if you don't
know, like you're a baby. humble like
very humble like a child and then just
say I all I said was
Jesus if you are like what Christians
are saying show me and in that moment
well I grew up with lots of um just bad
emotions feeling empty feeling
unfulfilled feeling um like trying to
chase something that's missing I don't
know if you know what I'm talking about
um and then in that moment that whole
thing just went away was failed
completely. It's like I never needed
anything. I was in complete happiness
and joy. I I um it was like almost like
being in heaven. I guess that's what it
feels like. Yeah. I feel exactly the
same because I'm actually bultural. I
think you call it. My mom is an Arab. My
dad is European who converted to marry
my mom. Uh and yes, I relate to this
lack of identity. So I I don't I used to
live in a Muslim country. I moved uh to
my home country from my father's side. I
live right the church is like uh I can
see it from the window outside of my
apartment. Wow. Uh and I'm surrounded by
this new culture which is technically
mine. So I'm I'm very confused and I
hear the sermon some I don't know if you
call it sermons or mass. Yeah, that's
yeah. Yeah, I hear it sometimes. And I
heard uh on Easter actually I heard uh
the sermon about uh how uh even the
disciples didn't believe fully until
they saw his empty grave or something
like this. And yeah, it piqued my
interest. So I brought I brought a Bible
and uh in my head I was thinking like I
cannot go into this. I'll lose my
family. And then I just opened some
random page and it was actually in
Matthew uh where it talks about that I
came to turn your father against his
son. And
um yeah, so that was I closed the Bible
and I was really scared. It was a very
creepy clothes. I I I was scared too. I
was secret for about six months. But
don't worry about that first. like your
your priority is like you're in your
dream to be saved from from death from
from destruction, you know, which is
hell basically. But um I would say just
the first the first thing you need to be
is free in your mind and in your heart
and um just take the first step I would
say and the thing about your family and
all that stuff um the Lord will sort
that out in time.
Um, I can say looking back at it, um,
your mind thinks that it's going to be
worse than it is, but if you know, don't
don't do something that will endanger
you. I don't know what your situation
is, but I I wouldn't worry about that at
the moment. I would worry about just
getting myself saved. So, do you know
what it what what it means to be like to
be saved by Jesus? Do you know what that
means? Uh, the only thing that comes to
mind is when he literally saved me in my
dream. That's okay.
Well, Jesus is the savior in the Bible.
That's that's his name. He's the savior.
Jesus saves. That's his name. Yeshua.
So, he came to save us from our sins. So
So, everybody sinned and they deserve
hell because we sinned. Um I know Islam
tells Yeah.
They everyone before Jesus sinned or us
now currently? All humans. All humans
before and after everybody. Everybody
sinned. Everybody did something wrong.
Yes.
So the way Islam deals with that, it
tells you that if you do more right than
wrong, that that can save you. But
that's not the case because any judge
will tell you that if you do something
wrong, it doesn't matter what else
you've done right. You need to pay for
what you did for the bad bad that you
did. Yeah. So it's it's the same thing.
That's what God tells us in the Bible.
You've all broken my law.
That means you know you've all gone
astray. You've all you all fallen short
of the glory of God. Which means the
glory of God is his law, his perfection.
So we've all none of us deserve to be
with him for eternity, right? None of us
do. So what happens is this judgment,
the punishment for what we did. Like if
you say you pay a fine, it has to fall
on somebody. Someone has needs to pay
your fine so you can be free. So that's
how Jesus saves us from hell. He paid
that punishment. And since everybody
sinned, no one can pay for anybody
else's punishment. They need to pay for
their own. So Jesus who had no sin took
everybody's punishment on himself. And
because he has eternal
value, that value that punishment um
that sa saving grace covers everybody is
enough to cover the whole world. But
it's a gift. You can't force people to
take it. You have to come. So that so
that means you have to come to him and
accept that he accept that gift say yes
you can pay my fine and that's how you
can get saved.
Thank you for explaining. I never
understood what it means like what it
means that he died for our sins and it
makes sense in my head. It's like uh
like if you
uh curse out your friend, you can
apologize, but if you curse out the
president, you might end up in jail. So
what about uh you know doing cursing God
or like how how are you supposed to pay
him for that? So he sends a part of
himself to repay him because that's the
only uh sorry English is not my first
language. Do you speak Arabic? If you
struggle at all, you can say something
in Arabic and we can translate a little
bit. Like it's it doesn't it's the only
thing that measures up
to an apology for him. like you there's
no other way to apologize as big as him
sacrificing himself if it makes sense.
Exactly. Well, the Bible does say that
the actual punishment is death. Um it
says the way for sin for doing something
wrong against God himself. Um by the
way, if you wrong anybody, it's it's
like you've wronged God. Like God says
that in the Psalms. Um David says
against you only you did I sin. So if
you wrong someone, it's against God. If
you wrong yourself, it's against God.
Um, and God says the the punishment for
that is death. Like you say, the
president, it's it's higher. So God is
the highest. So you have to pay for your
life. So what did Jesus do? He paid with
his life as a substitution for yours. So
you don't have to pay. And that's the
only way you can get saved. So what you
need to do is um like Romans 10, it
says, you have to say with your mouth
that Jesus is Lord. Like you said, he's
he's from God. He's God in the flesh.
You have to say that realize I said
that.
Yeah. He says you have to say with your
mouth, Jesus is Lord and believe in your
heart that God raised him from the dead,
which is, you know, when he came back
from the dead and then that you will be
saved when you do this.
Okay. Thank you so
much. Do you want do you want one of us
to pray for you or maybe you can pray?
It's very nice when you
offer. I also want to try what you did
uh to call for
him.
Uh yeah, I'm just scared. I I'm I'm very
I get scared very quickly. So I'm scared
to like if he appeared in front of me, I
would lose my mind. So what he come he
he knows he knows like who you are and
he knows you better than you even know
yourself. The Bible says that he know
every single hair on your head is
numbered. So God is not going to do
something that he knows that you can't
handle. He won't give you anything that
you can't handle. So he's not God will
not scare you. And remember Jesus has
always been with you. Um you may not
know it or realize it but um we know
from the Bible that everything and
everyone was created through him. It
says that in John 1. So you were created
through Jesus actually through the word
of God who is Jesus. And um the Bible
says that ever since you were in the
mother's womb, he know he's known you.
So you may have only just started to
know him now or he's come to you now,
made himself known to you in the dream
now and put us put this life in your
path now when you ask for a sign. But
he's always known you. He's known you
more than your parents, more than
yourself. So there's a familiarity with
Jesus and there's a comfort with Jesus
that you won't find anywhere else. And
that's that's what I experienced anyway
when I called out to him. And when I
read his words in the Bible, um, they
seemed familiar. Like they seemed like
I've heard this before. Like I've
thought this before. I've heard this
before. Even though I hadn't read the
Bible before and I'd read the Quran
more, so Quran was more familiar. But
the Bible when you read it, it's like
he's with me. Like for example, when
Jesus said um
uh when you fast, anoint your head um
and wash your face so that your fasting
may not be seen by others. I always
wondered why people have Muslims had to
make every everybody know that they're
fasting. They say Allah everybody in
Ramadan knows you're fasting. Like it
should be something between you and God.
And when Jesus said, you know, um, he
rebuked people who would pray in the
street corners and make a show of
prayer. Um, and I don't know, you know,
your upbringing, but as a Muslim, my mom
always wanted to see me pray and Muslims
pray condemned this publicly.
Yes. Yeah. He condemned this. Jesus
condemned this. So he said, he said,
"No, when you pray, go to your closet
and pray to your father in secret." So
that then your father in secret who
who's in secret will reward you. To me
that makes more sense. If I pray that's
between me and God. Why does everybody
else need to see? Now as as a Muslim I
thought that but I never knew Jesus said
it. So when I read it in the Bible I
said ah he knows he knows what I
thought. So that's what I mean by
familiar. So I don't want this. So it's
very it make me smile. It's very nice.
Yeah. Exactly. So don't be scared like
he's he's your god. He's the one who
created you. who knows all your thoughts
and um this is really exciting because I
don't know what you think Joy but I
think God has really moved to save you.
Praise God. Yes. Yes. And don't delay.
Please go into your room or wherever you
feel you know you can go and speak to
him.
Okay. Thank you so much. Yeah. And he he
will answer you. He'll answer you
too. You call out to him and he'll
answer you.
I bit unworthy but I will try. We all
are. All are us. All of us. All of us. I
mean, yeah. All of us. No, no one is
worthy. But then
Jesus is not He doesn't give out of
worthiness. It's not Islam when you get
stuff you deserve because you work hard.
No, no, no. It's out of love and grace.
Yeah.
Thank you so much. I'm sorry, David, for
blocking you.
I'm blocking. Hey, I block I block
myself sometimes when I annoy myself.
So, you're good.
Um, I want to I did block AP first a
year ago. So, I I don't blame you for
that. I don't blame you. Yeah, he
probably he probably deserved it. He
probably
just joking. I want to I want to share
this verse uh that's that's on my mind.
um when you said that you know you don't
feel like you were even worthy enough to
call out for to him or for him to even
appear which is the same for all of us
the Bible speaks to this and this is one
of those things that DLC was talking
about about familiarity how you already
said that the Bible watch what the Bible
says here it says this in chapter in
Romans chapter 5 7-9 it says for one
will scarcely die for a righteous person
though perhaps for a good person one
would even dare to die. But God shows
his love for us in that while we were
still sinners, Christ died for us. Since
therefore we have now been justified by
his blood, much more shall we be saved
by him from the wrath of God. And so
notice when he does this, he doesn't do
this when we are good, when we are in
right standing with God. It says God
shows his love for us in that while we
were still sinners. Miriam, you're not
even a Christian yet. You're not even
you haven't pronounced your faith in
Christ at all yet. While you're still
not a Christian, he has showed himself
to you. He's been calling out to you and
pulling on your heart. So, this is what
the Bible says. It's he loves you. He
loves you.
So, I just wanted to share that with
you. Thank you. Uh can you repeat the
which verse it was? I'll just Yeah.
Yeah. Uh I'll put it on the screen
again. So it's uh it is Romans chapter 5
verse 7
to9 specifically verse 8. Romans chapter
5:8 specifically it says here but God
shows his love for us in that while we
were still sinners Christ died for us.
So, it's expressing how nobody's going
to die for someone who's unrighteous,
let alone somebody might even dare.
Somebody might think about dying for for
a righteous person, but they still
probably won't do it. But Christ came
and he died for sinners, for unrighteous
people. That's how much he loved
us. And that's how much he loves you by
showing himself up to you. Even though
you're not a even haven't pro professed
to be a Christian yet, he loves you and
he's showing up for you. So,
thank you so much for
Thank you. I'm sorry for taking your
time. I know it's not the topic, but I I
didn't think it was a coincidence that I
asked for a sign and I've never watched
your stuff before and your life just
David's blocked. You're not even in my
history and your life,
bro. Praise God. We thank God for that.
Miriam, I want to let you know you're
always welcome here. Um even after, you
know, whatever happens within this
journey, I you're welcome to come back
and share what has gone on and what's
where you're at in your journey. I want
to I want to be I'm invested now. I'm
like, you know, I'm watching the show
now. It's like, you know, I'm in this.
So, don't leave me hanging. Come back
and and let us know. Give us some
updates and and where you are. Okay.
Okay. Thank you so much. For sure. All
right. God bless you, Miam. You're
welcome anytime. It doesn't matter. It
doesn't matter what the topic is. You're
welcome anytime. If you could uh pray
for me, I would appreciate it also. Oh,
yes. DLC, did you want to pray? Okay,
let's pray for
Miriam. Father God, we thank you so much
for uh this precious uh lady, Miriam. We
thank you that you have reached out to
her and have come to her and showed her
that Jesus can save her. We thank you
for um everyone who has
um led her perhaps with a word or um
with a stream or with anything online or
offline to you. We pray Lord for her
that you give her the ability to come to
you to understand your great rescue from
hell, your great salvation. Uh we pray
Lord for your spirit to uh lead her to
the truth and uh for uh her protection
and um Lord that you remove any fear or
worry that she might have uh as she
comes to you. We pray Lord that um you
lead her to to you. Um and Lord that she
would become one one of your children
and that she would uh follow the Lord
Jesus and u be saved by him in Jesus
name. Amen. Amen. God bless you Miam.
Thank you so much for coming. You
blessed the stream today sister. Thank
you. Thank you so much. Take care.